I'm scared professor dumbledore everyone  is scared of something weird is this  mute you're up next  what mr. Scamander fears above  everything else is having to work in an  office sir go ahead  [Music]  magic rooms only in rare Souls still in  sculpting shattered but the old ways  serve us no longer been evolved  television that it will rise to  dominance over the Wizarding World  you're asking me to help hunt him down  I can't move against Grendel fault it  has to be you in your shoes I'd probably  refuse to breathing it come on  [Music]  you underestimate your talents misters  come on  arrogance is a key to our victory  muggles are not lesser  and of this principle  what you couldn't you never met a  monster you couldn't learn Swedish  mr. Scamander do you think tumble to  will more for her  [Music]  are you goat  no but I'm an alchemist them therefore  immortal oh you're gonna fly man  Jacob croisé oh oh you don't look a day  over 375  [Music]  you  you